-We have exactly
11 shows left before
we go on Christmas break,
which means it's time for
that beloved
"Tonight Show" tradition.
It's time for "12 Days of
Christmas Sweaters."
-♪ 12 Days of
Christmas Sweaters ♪
♪ 11 days left ♪
-That's right -- every show
between now and Christmas,
we'll be giving
one lucky audience member
a marvelous Christmas sweater
from the
Countdown to Christmas Cabinet.
Now, since there are 11 shows
left, let's open door number 11.
You ready? You ready?
Go for it.
[ Drumroll ]
Ooh!
[ Laughs ]
♪♪
Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow!
-Alright. Now let's see
who's going home with
tonight's Christmas sweater.
Everyone look at
your seat number.
If I call your number, get up,
scream, come on down here,
and get ready for your
new Christmas sweater.
Who wants one?
Quest, can I get
a drumroll, please?
[ Drumroll ]
428!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Whoa!
♪♪
-What's going on?
Coming in -- coming in hot
right now.
You're coming in hot.
-I hope that was my number.
-You knew it was your number.
Yeah. Hi. How you doing?
-I'm good, Jimmy. How are you?
I'm Joe.
-Joe, nice to meet you.
Welcome, Joe.
Where are you from?
-From Navarre, Florida.
Originally from
Western New York. Go, Bills.
-Are you really?
Welcome back to New York.
Thanks for coming to
the show tonight.
-Absolutely.
-Do you have anything like this?
Well, you do.
-Not at all. I do now.
-You do now.
Would you like to try it on?
-I would love to.
-Yeah.
I'll hold your sweater for you.
♪♪
There you go.
-It's a lot heavier than I --
-Yeah, it's a hefty --
-Oh, yeah.
-It's like two sweaters in one.
-I'm sweatin' already.
-Yeah, no,
you're gonna love this.
This is good.
It's got good shoulders
in there for you, too.
-Oh, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah!
Joe, you look good, bud.
Look at you.
-That looks awesome.
-Look at that.
You look good, right?
-Couple handsome guys we are.
-Yeah, I like that.
That's what I'm talking about.
Joe, thank you very much.
Nice to see you.
Give it up for Joe.
Stick around.
We got more "Tonight Show"
after the break.
♪♪
Coming running out?